un homenaje a las casi 600 mil víctimas
mortales que deja el kobe 19 en eeuu
desde el inicio de la pandemia
un grupo de líderes del congreso
estadounidense se reunió las afueras del
capitolio para recordarlos y honrarlos
con un minuto de silencio la cifra total
de muertos por el virus en el país es
igual a la cantidad de estadounidenses
que murieron de cáncer en 2019 y mucho
mayor al número de habitantes de
ciudades como miami atlanta durante su
visita a europa el presidente joe biden
reconoció este hito sombrío y siguió
instando a los estadounidenses a
vacunarse contra el kobe 19 a pesar de
que el número de muertes diarias ha
disminuido drásticamente y en medio del
escepticismo de un gran número de
ciudadanos
por eso les sigo diciendo a eeuu si no
se han vacunado vacunen se vacunen se lo
antes posible
tenemos muchas vacunas en muchos sitios
tenemos más trabajo por hacer para
vencer este virus y ahora no es el
momento de bajar la guardia así que por
favor vacunarse ya hemos tenido
suficiente dolor de acuerdo con el
centro para el control y prevención de
enfermedades el 43 7% del total de la
población ha sido completamente
inoculada mientras que el 52% ha
recibido al menos
una dosis la alta reserva de vacunas en
eeuu ha llevado a ciudadanos de países
de américa latina a visitar el país para
aplicársela la mayoría de las
restricciones se han levantado en toda
la unión americana entre ellas el uso
obligatorio de mascarillas y se espera
que eeuu vuelva a la normalidad para el
4 de julio el día de su independencia
una fecha para la cual el país comenzará
a independizarse del virus según lo
prometido por el mismo baile